I thought it was sort of sad in the book
when you're talking about now when you
look in the mirror literally a lot of
the big muscles are gone you don't like
looking what do you call the belly the
boodle the the uh the Bole the the Bole
the Bole it's fun in another way because
I I kind of smile because every day I do
look you know in a mirror and I say yep
you
suck look at this body look at the look
at the the spectral muscles that used to
be firm and perky and kind of like
really powerful with a station in there
now they're just hanging there I mean
what the hell is going on here you know
it said also because as I said to people
it's one thing to see yourself get older
and more and more out of shape but most
of the people are not really never have
been in shape so what does it mean
getting out of shape they've always
looked at the shitty body so therefore
they they can it gets shitty as time
goes on it's just when you have been
hailed for years as this supreme body
you know and you have the definition and
you see the veins coming down your abs
and you see veins on top of your chest
all you were Superman I know you see all
this stuff and now then now you cut and
you roll the clock for about 50 years
and now you're standing there and you
don't see that anymore so that's kind of
like wow you know I never ever thought
about that when I was like 30 years old
or 40 years old that this is going to
happen that you know we one time we're
going to look at this body and uh it
still looks better than majority of
bodies but I mean it it just sucks you
have to accept your Humanity it's hard
right when you were Superman at one
absolutely but you stay always lean I'm
always amazed about how lean you stay
you don't gain any weight you just stay
but it's smart you can only live longer
and healthier if you're Lean Like I eat
only two meals a day I have breakfast
and have dinner I don't have lunch
because the system just slows down and
it just doesn't burn off the stuff that
did well anymore does it ever freak you
out that your body turned on you in the
sense that like you had you talk about
in your book your heart situation where
you had this operation and they they
messed it up but whatever your body was
trying to kill you absolutely just
before I turned 50 I had the heart
surgery that's when I kind of afterwards
kind of came out of it and they said you
know you now damaged goods this is the
first time where I felt kind of like
vulnerable where all of a sudden the
doctor says you know you shouldn't lift
that heavy anymore or just pay attention
when you uh breathe when you exercise
you know exhale don't keep the a pressed
inside because there is too much stress
on your valves in your heart and all of
a sudden there was dialogue like that
life is not anymore the same as when it
was like 30 years old or 40 years old
where you could do anything and you
never had to think about anything now
all a sudden you have to start thinking
about those things to warm up for this
to warm up for that but am I upset about
it no because there's nothing that I can
do about it I just feel like as those
challenges come my way I take them on
you know because it's it's the only
choice we have the bottom line is I'm 76
years old I'm full of energy I'm full of
enthusiasm I'm as en enthusiastic and as
excited as I was when I was 30 years old
I just always see mountains in front of
me to be climbed and so as long as I see
those mountains I keep my enthusiasm and
I keep my excitement and that fire in a
belly to keep climbing and climbing and
climbing and that's what it's all
about